can get you home oh
and give you more time it's a banana Sky
yeah it's I love that effect so much
it's important that he gets unravel it
was like oh now that I see it again it
was more liquidy something I didn't yeah
that was a soupy poopy
welcome back to new rock stars today
we're talking more on Ant-Man on the
watch Quantum media so if you're
watching this I'm taking it that you've
seen quantumania and if you haven't just
look away listen to us but look away
because we're gonna spoil it we're gonna
spoil it like a little bit only an
ant-sized bit today we're going to be
talking more about the probability storm
and Schrodinger's box and what causes
people or figments of your imagination
or what have you to like
unravel like big Scott we want to thank
nordvpn for sponsoring our show today
more on them in a bit this is inside
Marvel new Rockstar's weekly Marvel
reaction show and I'm Jessica Clemens
here with me is Eric Voss and Mt what's
going on they all said we're all gonna
die how do we know that you know that
big Scott died maybe he was like mantis
after she got turned into ribbon she's
still he's still playing that's true or
it could be true Mr Fantastic and he
could just you know I don't know
who knows like maybe he's just like
sentient spaghetti and just like he was
still moving like but we just didn't see
him moving he's just moving at spaghetti
I don't know please I can't remember my
legs
to check out nerdriot.shop where you can
always grab the latest and greatest new
rockstars gear right now our quantumania
Inspire merch is 15 off through the end
of the month also our brand new
Mandalorian inspired Birches drop it on
the channel this week like a bunch of
foundlings looking for the way and a lot
of foundlings that died on the way
support the channel
new rockstarsmerch.com or nerdriot.shop
you can go to either one they still work
and I think we have both our boys again
wearing merch and me you already know
like this hoodie is like I think my
favorite hoodie right now like this
conquer hoodie is just so dope and I
love the lasagna in the back it's just
like I don't know I just feel cool rep
and Kang in this hoodie and it's like
comfortable on my skin so and it's very
cold in um New England so like this is
primo Kang sweater time so yeah I'm
rocking some of the Deep dive collection
stuff over here I'm such a shill I get
it you know there's lunch party on
Friday I was wearing our a deep dive
hoodie and everyone made fun of me
they're like why are you wearing stuff
I'm like I don't have clothes I don't
have anything other than neurons
it's kind of sad but we absolutely do
and that's why I'm always I wear my
clothes that are not new rock stars
merch to make you guys feel bad that is
the only reason I wear my clothes like
please encourage me to be a normal human
being because this is not normal
but we also want to remind you guys
because of what Eric's wearing because
of our launch party our new channel the
Deep dive you can find all sorts of
great content from the mind of Eric Boss
including his recent deep dive into
everything everywhere all at once
subscribe to the deep thought so you
don't miss out and literally number one
I don't care what anyone says to me
number one movie of all time give
Michelle all the Oscars steal the Oscars
from other people that got the Oscars
and give it to Michelle yeah let's just
Rob everyone else's Oscars and then give
them yes this sounds like a great movie
of like a heist that the three of us go
on to break into Liberty mansions and
steal their Oscars just to give them to
Michelle you know yes
uh but we can't steal her from Angela
Bassett because she did the thing so we
can't do that
she did the thing apparently uh that's a
reference to uh the the Baptist the
Baptist Angela Bassett did the thing
Viola Davis my woman King horrible you
guys Eric I'll send it to you it's
horrible okay so let's get into our
first question because I can't talk
about what that atrocity was that was at
the Baptist what is the probability
storm caused by King's energy Corps and
what causes it really so base level of
understanding truly I guess the question
is what is uh the energy course
probability field we know it creates
every potential outcome for the person
inside of it manifested into various
versions of themselves basically like
Schrodinger's Box there's a ton multiple
simultaneous outcomes it's only when
solved the probability like reduces and
in this case it's all the ant-man's I
think recognizing Cassie's their
motivation this might be like a science
question in whole but how come going
inside of it makes you lose your mind
and how come you're not fighting your
own outcomes that second question I just
want to say like
like uh and Rick and Morty there's an
episode where Jerry and Beth use space
marriage counseling and they create
perceptions of their partners and Jerry
creates a monster Tyrant scorpion lady
while Beth creates a slug then when you
put the device on the created
perceptions it makes more perception of
that perception So what at what point do
your perceptions disagree in just class
Clash so that's like that's what I meant
for the second question of like when do
they just start disagreeing and fighting
each other we kind of saw it with hope
but I guess that's the second part of
the question sorry there's a loaded
question how does it work how does the
probability work that's you're that's
such a good question like I think like
there's probably an answer rooted in
quantum physics and an answer rooted in
uh metaphysics and in love and in Souls
I mean I've gone into this a bit in the
Deep dive but I think you know I've
talked about this before I know Mt
you've thought about this of this whole
idea of a dance battle to save the
Universe I think we're in the midst of a
dance battle to save the Multiverse and
that we uh we can divide all beings that
exist in the Multiverse into dancers and
non-dancers
um non-dancers are people who like to
work solo uh dancers are people who need
kind of their tribe of multiversal
variants to work together and with you
know some people already discovered that
within a single Universe they can kind
of find their tribe of people whether
it's a group of thunderbolts or a group
of Guardians the Galaxy or a group of
Avengers and some people don't fit into
any of those groups and kind of need
themselves and Loki is the first I think
multiversal dancer that we've met
um but they exist everywhere I think
Scott is the second one that we meet and
I think gang um okay the Kang Dynasty is
defined by the fact that they fear each
other they don't trust each other but we
see in this moment the all the
multiversal Scots and they aren't there
are possibilities right so it's really
just a hypothetical rather than an
actual
um but I think we are seeing what it
looks like when um a hive of different
possibilities can just instinctively
sink and synchronize and what
synchronizes them is I think uh the
shared love that they have for their
daughter or rather the shared guilt they
have of her being a bad dad yeah yeah
that's true that's true that's more of a
metaphysics answer I'm not a quantum
physics though no it's the question
itself was going to be heavy no no I
think symbolically
um like this sequence in the movie is
supposed to symbolize the concept of um
of choice in like how your choice can
Branch off into different variants and
so symbolically it's it's sort of
mirroring what we saw in Loki
um with um the timelines and how
um you making a specific choice or a
different Choice can create a different
branching timeline and I think that you
know with Scott branching into different
um Scots like it only really happened
when it seemed like Scott needed to make
a choice like that's particular Scott
copy needed to make a different Choice
like left or right and I think that
um you know this sequence could
potentially just or it happening in the
quantum realm
um like a place where like it's
basically a Nexus point between like the
the Multiverse like it's basically
saying like all right this is the place
of the most potential Like Anything
could happen like you can do anything
and create your own timeline from here
um so I think that the quantum realm may
be special
um and like because like I think the
probability storm could have been native
to the quantum realm to begin with
because like we saw at the beginning of
the movie where those bugs split like
Scott did before that um before Janet
even launched her bomb so I think that
the quantum realm itself
has probability storms from time to time
and um you know Janet and I mean Ant-Man
2 mentions probability fields to Hank
when like she's working through Scott
and I think that like those probability
Fields could be something that Janet was
already used to
um in the quantum realm while she was
there that's such an interesting idea I
I love that
it it it gives okay so okay there's
multiple reasons why I love this I love
that and I think that it has to be true
because and and this might be the
loosest terms uh dumbed down for myself
what's the difference between this
probability field and like what Doctor
Strange was doing when he saw all the
multiple outcomes right I guess my
question is like why can't tangentially
Doctor Strange have created something
like the probability field is it because
it was in the quantum realm is it
because it's Quantum energy uh versus
Mystic Arts or are they along the same
lines are they parallel that's that's
interesting because they think you're
right just to compare them that they're
both hypothetical rather than practical
like strange is is witnessing the future
I guess there's an argument to be made
that he's living through it but I think
it's that moment in Infinity war was
more of a witness scene and what's
happening to Scott in the in the
probability storm is a hypothetical it
is something that is inside of his mind
and messing with him like physically in
the way that your mind is your matter
um but I think yeah I think they are too
different ways to explain the same the
same psychological syndrome and I
honestly think the name of that
psychological syndrome is quantumania I
think that is like when you're
overwhelmed by your life paths I think
that is what Quantum media means so
Hanks aunts and Hanks ants so Scott Lang
or even Baskin Robbins Scotland couldn't
touch hopes
perception of herself
but they could touch each other because
they were physically there does that
make sense that's my question they
couldn't Hank's ants so
so Scott Lang's uh a million
probabilities himself of himself the
various versions of him can't touch the
million versions of Hope when she
entered right it's just hope her
physical self-hope can touch physical
Hank or physical scope I'm so sorry yeah
I think that's what it is I think that's
what we mean by it being all in his head
he can kind of sense and see the other
Scots
um I I don't know if hope can see them
she can perceive them but I think she
can only actually touch the ones that
are real that makes sense or the one
that is real but I guess that begs the
question then why did Scott see a big
boy unraveling and I wonder if it's just
that one just got too far away from the
norm it was more Scott's fear of trying
to escape that like stunned him into
staying small and working with his Hive
like in some weird way his anxiety he
kept him on the correct life path of
having to work with his Hive and teach
him like that would have implied their
kind of divinity fate Destiny among the
Multiverse that is guiding all
multiversal variants on a path to learn
how to work with each other did I just
lose myself I think I lost myself I'm
sorry I like it it goes into our second
question it goes into our second one I
wanted to go over the probability field
because the main meat substance of this
inside Marvel is about big Scott
unraveling and to know big Scott
unraveling we need to know the
probability field so or the probability
storm empty I really love that idea of
uh the possibility of probability storms
being something that is part of the
ecosystem of the quantum realm at large
do you think it's possible that this was
brought in by the invasive species of
kings of Kang's ecosystem like when he
dropped it in there for one like I
thought it was interesting how on each
of those bands there's that curvy like
circular written language and we see
that throughout the quantum realm as if
it kind of trickled out and was adopted
did by the quantum realm and it seems
like Kang introduced a lot of these
things like and they called it a
probability storm how would Modoc and
all them know what a probability storm
unless those storms could flow outward
from the crashed wreckage of it and just
kind of affect and screw up the
ecosystem of the quantum like I don't
know if it started with Kang or if it
was true the quantum realm and Kang was
just affected by it that's what I don't
know yeah like it's that's the big
mystery like I I just need I need more
I've only seen this movie one time so
like I just I want to see it again so I
can just like really just absorb
everything that happens especially at
the beginning when uh Kane first arrives
and meets Janet because like I want to
see why
um those creatures started to freak out
and did do the thing that they split the
way that they did because um I think
that maybe potentially the actual crash
King's crash could have affected the the
nearby flora and fauna potentially and
uh caused them to have Quantum freakouts
and he created that probability storm
with the actual crash or maybe it's just
native to the to the actual area I I'm
not sure
um but no I I like all I like your ideas
a lot there's so much we don't know
about the concert despite it being a
movie that is mostly set in the quantum
realm we don't know much about the
history of the quantum realm they ask
the questions but they don't really God
Marvel they do this every time
they like show us the cool looking place
but don't really give us any sense of
like how it evolved or where it came
from I know I feel like this is the
beginning of like the just like the our
relationship with the quantum realm
because much like you know we see Asgard
like merging with Earth and sort of I
think and we see like different parts of
like uh the cosmos coming to Earth I
think that we're gonna see veb just
chilling in like I don't know Florida or
like or they're just chilling like just
chilling in America one day because like
they're gonna find a way to open up a
portal and like there's something about
the actual look of the people of the
quantum realm that gives me a very like
taikawa tt-esque Vibe and like it makes
me think that maybe a future Hulk
Adventure could find the Hulk in the
quantum realm um in like Taiko T2
potentially like doing another Hulk type
Adventure there because like um it just
felt like a very interesting world that
like he would probably tackle
um in his own
um
um because like we know hulken in the
comics
um it has a relationship in the quantum
real I mean he has a hit he had a wife
in the quantum realm um and he had that
um a whole Adventure down there so I
think that we could potentially see that
in the future but anyway either way the
quantum realm is probably going to be a
another
um just another force in the Marvel
Universe much like Asgard or wakanda I
think it is going to be a new it's a new
Destiny wakanda forever I can't wait
till wakanda to take over the quantum
realm okay
but hey guys before we continue guys you
know we love watching content here at
new rockstars but it stinks when we go
to watch a movie or series only to
discover that it's not currently
available for streaming here in the US
one way to get more content options in
your life is to check out nordvpn with
nordvpn you can change your virtual
location with just one click which makes
it easier to find streaming platforms at
a lower price we can even access
platforms that aren't available in the
United States and when I'm traveling I
can use nordvpn to keep up with all my
favorite shows while I'm away and plus
nordvpn's benefits and features go Way
Beyond improving your streaming
experience you can also access games and
discounts only available in other
regions and block malware written
websites while you explore securely and
you can also use nordvpn for up to six
devices that's pretty um convenient we
encourage you to try nordvpn for
yourself so grab your exclusive nor VPN
deal by going to nordvpn.com Marvel to
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus four additional months for
free it's going completely risk-free
with norad's 30-day money-back guarantee
that is Nord
n-o-r-d-v-p-n.com slash Marvel for an
exclusive discount plus four months for
free You're Gonna Want to get a good
night's sleep before seeing Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania or even after
seeing Ant-Man and was quantum Maniac
because these movies are long and here
at new rockstars We Trust our sleepy
time with Helix and we have for many
many years Helix makes premium
mattresses and bedding that are
customized to fit your needs and
conveniently shipped right to your door
which Helix mattress is right for you
don't worry about it Helix made a sleep
quiz that matches your unique body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress just for you based on your
different sleep positions and firmness
preferences they have something for
everyone's unique taste and if you sleep
with a partner you can take the Sleep
quiz together and find something that's
perfect to compromise for the both of
you because you guys need to get each
other's own sleep I love my Helix
mattress I just recently realized that
it is cold it is meant to be cold and
that's why I've been freezing at night
because I run hot because I run hot and
I'd rather be cold than running hot and
sweating all over my mattress like I did
the last 28 years the best part about
all of this is that Helix delivers your
mattress right to your door with free
shipping in the US plus Helix has a 100
night sleep trial so you get more than
three months to make sure that you love
it or you'll get a full refund Helix
mattresses have 10 year warranty and
they even offer financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never too far away I
love my Helix and I think you would love
yours too if you're looking for a new
bed check out Helix you can click the
link below or go to helixsleep.com
inside Marvel to get 20 off your Helix
mattress plus two free pillows that's
helixsleep.com inside Marvel also we
want to thank Turbo Tax for sponsoring
this episode go to Turbo Tax and don't
do your taxes meet with an expert who
will do them for you Turbo Tax experts
can relieve you from the stress of taxes
and file for you so you can do not taxes
show your eyes things that are not taxes
unpack a moving box of not taxes taste
not taxes sing not taxes a lullaby hope
not taxes sleeps through the night grab
a saddle and ride not taxes into the
sunset with Turbo Tax an expert will do
your taxes from start to finish ensuring
your taxes are done right guaranteed so
you can relax feels good to be done with
your taxes doesn't it come to Turbo Tax
and don't do your taxes visit
turbotax.com to learn more Intuit
TurboTax full service products only
video meeting while expert does your
taxes required C guaranteed details at
turbotax.com guarantees second question
for inside Marvel How does the energy
core cause big Scott to just unravel we
see all the scared frantic Scots rushing
in different directions we see big Scott
truly unravel but hope didn't right I
don't think she did uh but could this be
his subconscious is his mind unraveling
and so is he like is he just breaking
down kind of what vas said is it just
like his anxiety of all of this or is
this more in line with Schrodinger's Box
I also want to keep both of you guys in
mind that in Multiverse Madness Wanda
did this to Mr Fantastic so could this
be where the quantum realm meets Mystic
Magic we don't know but but why did he
unravel why yeah I'm sorry I got ahead
of this like I think I think it is
interesting to explore the angle that
Scott is this is just Scott's
possibility it's a hypothetical
possibility that is in his head and this
is to keep him on the path of working
together rather than growing bigger than
his variants and escaping from his
variants he's gotta work with not be a
solo act
um however just because it is in the
mind doesn't mean it isn't real
Dumbledore says that I mean the way it
collapses the strands collapsed it seems
fleshy and wet you know doesn't it seem
like it's real or it's meant to be seen
as real kind of like a cautionary tale
of what will happen to you if you stop
working with your partners the old Wanda
Witch will get you interior shreds
they've receive like a ghost story
bedtime story cautionary tale to Scott
of how why to stay with each other I
think even the way that it unraveled
like how you said how is like wet paint
is also in essence to what what he's
feeling it's like imagine paint just
falling down and crumbling I also think
that to him it's like my entire life is
falling apart it's unraveling and this
is what's happening to him but for
someone else it's like I'm feeling
crushed right now I'm feeling suffocated
maybe they're just getting completely
demolished into like the size of a can
or they're getting crushed into a flat
cylinder
um so I I think I believe that I'm like
yeah I think it's just how he feels
subconsciously if it's perceptions of
himself and probabilities of his own
outcomes I think this is also our
perception of probability of his of
himself and his own outcomes I like that
like those both those ideas I really
like those I think that I don't know
because like like
um Eric said before like we've seen like
the unraveling images like before in
previous Marvel movies like we saw in um
in Multiverse of Madness like oh someone
like Jess said before
um and we saw it in um Infinity War when
Thanos used the reality Stone to unravel
a mantis
um and so I think that this might be I
think that chaos magic or chaos energy
rather could be in play because like we
know that pin particles
um are usually red like the the Scott
uses a red type of energy disc to shrink
down and I think that those pin
particles within Scott allow Scott to
make duplicates of himself
um
in like it's like in a in a really weird
way like a like a person native to the
quantum like a creature native to the
quantum realm could potentially do I
don't know um but anyway the point is
um I think that with if Scott were to
grow big and use a different type of
energy it might like stretch his atoms
like a little bit too much and so like
that symbol that image of him unraveling
is just like sort of like uh you pulling
a thread it's like all right
everything's unraveling because like all
the your atomic structure is just messed
up and now you're just like becoming
noodles because your atoms don't want to
do what they're supposed to do and
connect
um I don't know this all makes sense in
my head
I have no idea what I'm saying I saw
like a senile old man I was obsessed
with the idea of it also coming in
contact with Quant with uh like Wanda's
magic because again like VA said we
don't know much about the quantum realm
this movie did get into like literally
the hierarchy
um and the people but we don't know
where those people came from we don't
know has how deep it goes and whether or
not there is Magic already in the
quantum realm that we just don't know
about so if that magic plus the quantum
energy core came together and created
this outcome and it's just a devilish
hellscape it wouldn't be it wouldn't go
past me of like oh this is hell for
people this could be limbo
um the probability filled is just limbo
in the quantum realm yeah that's why I
think there might be some kind of
divinity some kind of rules of the
Multiverse beyond what Kang controls
like obviously the Multiverse is beyond
King The King Dynasty's control they're
terrified of it they don't really like
he's talking about how the others are
screwing it up they're worried that the
Avengers are screwing it up like I think
beyond that there was that one line
where Kang the Conqueror says I want to
declare war on eternity in the dynasty
of Kang so then Cassie Cuts him off with
her stupid Marvel wannabe speech but
then sorry I'm not crazy about Cassie in
this movie
but but he says uh declare one eternity
and like I don't think he can bring up
eternity in the MCU without like hinting
at at least the corporeal or however the
abstract form of Eternity that right now
does not really exist if you consider
her transmuting her form into mistress
love and Thor love and thunder or is
there still a form of Eternity that
exists I think there's some kind of
divine uh abstract deity that governs
all this and that could be the Living
Tribunal it could be eternity it could
be the seven of them in uh as part of
like a supreme court that governs all of
reality across the Multiverse and I
think they kind of set these rules uh
that that encourage you or incentivize
you to work with each other and to
restore the balance of everything I'm
here for that I support that I support
that I'm down for it I support that
whole
I also I just there's so many theories
there's so many things that people can
talk about in this movie because there
was a lot of to me a little unanswered
but I think those unanswered open doors
for people like us to brainstorm on
multiple outcomes to what it could be
and I really like the idea of being like
he wasn't really fully in charge of the
quantum realm his ability to take it
over like just to be like a king yes but
he didn't have control of it no one has
control of the quantum realm so I I have
a third question of what does this mean
for Kang that could still be living
inside the core but I think some of the
new rock stars is doing a video already
about this I love know who that could be
it's me yes no I think that there's
really exciting possibilities here
um with this King that supposedly died
in Quantum media I do not think that um
he's actually dead I think that we could
be seeing the stars of something new
um like try Roy and Gabriella said in
High School Musical one
um
[Laughter]
when does the video Drop so this video
is gonna drop sometime this weekend and
um it's gonna go into a version of Kang
that a lot of people don't really talk
about and I think that this is going to
be the version of Kang that Marvel is
going to use for it's gonna be it's
really interesting
that's all it's his butt what is it is
[Music]
we gonna talk about that in Phase five
and six that that's gonna be brought up
look then I got I got YouTube premium so
I skipped the commercials go straight to
the videos you heard it first here Mt is
doing the breakdown on Jonathan Major's
butts uh and that is it for this episode
of inside Marvel uh you guys please
anticipate that video because we all
know King is still alive and if they
want to blame off his dead we know that
they can come back to that anytime phase
six seven whatever they want they can
come back to that open door that he is
still alive there so go check out mt's
video on that because I know it's going
to be so great don't forget to check out
our many great Rich options at
newrockstars merch.com or nerdriot.shop
if you're over 18 click the link in the
new rockstars Discord server in the
description and join the conversation
follow me at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow Voss at eavos follow Mt at
mastertonment subscribe to inside Marvel
wherever you get your podcast thanks for
watching and bye and subscribe to the
Deep dive too oh just subscribe to
anytime
[Music]